welcome back today we're combining uh
two things that I really really love
which is interior design and cats
um so we called in some backup and
joining me is Purina veterinarian and my
friend Dr Cali Harris hello Dr Kelly
hello
um and we're teaming up with tidy care
comfort from Tidy Cats and we want to
refresh the living space of a Drew
gooder who actually cares for children
with special needs she has rescue cats
she's really special take a look at her
story my name is Danelle and my whole
world revolves around my cats teaching
dance and working with special needs
kids sit tumbles was found on the street
acrobat was six months old and about to
be euthanized but now my home is there
forever home they don't have to worry
about food or shelter or water like I
will go out of my way to do anything for
them I want to replace the cat tree add
wall perches and keep them out of each
other's food Acro gets violently ill
when he eats tumble spoon but our
biggest issue is the litter box I've
tried everything from newspaper to dust
free litter and no matter what I do I am
always vacuuming and sweeping Drew you
have four cats too many tips something I
should do
[Applause]
I do actually but Dr Kelly does as well
joining us here is Danelle heron
so Dr Polly what do you think about the
litter box number one is going to be one
litter box per cat an additional okay
okay second key tip is going to be
location location
so really creating a private area for
them to retreat to is going to be
fabulous I would love to show your space
before because he doesn't love a before
and after and gosh I hope you like what
we did this is what your space looked
like before cat friendly cute all right
everybody this is what we did
wow
[Applause]
okay so let me tell you how we started I
wanted to take away color from your
apartment which sounds depressing but
it's not I just figured with all this
special work that you do a space that
felt more Zen and Spa like to give
something back to yourself
and we have some fun
cat beds which I really like it is hard
to find cat accessories that are Chic
and this rug is very nice herringbone
this is amazing Dr Kelly tell us
everything I understand that Acro is on
a strict diet so it's going to be
important that you separate the two of
them when you feed them so take a look
here at this programmable Auto feeder
okay so then that way you can get the
food out for acro and then there's
another one tucked behind there for
tumbled yes yes something else I want to
point out you know Drew was she's
sitting on this fabulous carpet by the
way I'm like I would play with this you
know exactly and so a great way to
distract is by bringing in engagement
pieces very cat friendly ways to keep
their minds active so hopefully then
they won't destroy the carpet or those
nice panels that you picked out okay I
want to bring your attention to the
litter box so you also want to know
what's going on inside the litter box
and so choosing a cat litter like tidy
care Comfort where it truly does take
that cat preference when it comes to the
feel on their paws and that natural
fresh scent this is all going to help
support regular usage of the litter box
and so that's what's in the litter pan
that's tucked in in a nice discreet area
yeah and it is it's softer on their paws
so I just want to ask you is this okay
Beyond okay
you you are such a good person this is
amazing you're gonna love it and I think
her cats are gonna love it too yes I
think and they're the cutest cats by the
way
all right well Danelle you're not only
getting a year's supply of Tidy care
Comfort litter but also a Walmart plus
membership and that's not all everything
you see here it's all going home with
you like every single detail
all right there's more our entire
audience is actually going to go home
with the Walmart plus annual membership
gift card and
um
if you want to spruce up your cat's
litter box face Tidy Cats is actually
inviting cat owners to enter the Tidy
care refresh contest to win a chance at
a five thousand dollar litter box and
space home refresh with items from
Walmart
[Applause]
if you're interested in five thousand
dollars visit tidycare refresh.com thank
you Dr Cowley as of course always always
my pleasure always my pleasure thank you
all right everybody we'll be right back
[Music]